actually can I talk about the cat for a
second and and growler don't no
disrespect to you by them this is total
go for it you can do it that's
not inspirational that's suicidal
pickles goes for right there that's a
dead cat these are lies with telling
these people will liars think about why
do people buy these curds it's not
because they want to say how they feel
because they can't say how they feel
police are afraid to and you know what I
say to hell with it I say let's level
with America for a second at least let
them speak for themselves for once I
mean look at this one what's this one
saying congratulations on the new baby
how about congratulations on new baby
decides if I hang out nice knowing your
orbit this one with all the pre hearts
on the front honor this is a good one
definitely good one happy Valentine's
Day sweetheart I love you and that sweet
ain't love grand this is exactly why I'm
talking about oh what's that mean love
do you know do you know do you know does
anybody know what that means if somebody
gave me this car I would be it it's it's
these curds and the movies and the pop
stars they're to blame for the lies and
the heartache and and everything and we
responsible I'm responsible I think we
do it I think you do a bath in here
people should be able to say how they
feel how they really feel like not you
know where stranger putting words in the
mouth which like love that don't mean
anything I'm sorry i I'm sorry I quit
there's no in the world without
my help